well we're going to be talking about
your top 10 quarterbacks coming up in
about a half hour one guy who's yet to
croc crack the top ten but who is uh
getting a lot of attention to a tonga by
low of the fifth overall pick in the
draft he's got three starts now the hip
injury fine
but you know every time
the wednesday injury report comes out i
pull up the entire document and i do a
search a global search for qb and i just
next next next in the browser to see
which quarterbacks are on there right
and well there's two tongaviloa foot
injury fully participated in practice
but he's got his first nfl injury and i
i asked him after the win over the
chargers on sunday
you know what are you taking hits how's
it going he says oh i've taken plenty of
hits and i think i've i'm i'm fine thank
you i don't want any more yeah he
laughed he said i know that it's going
to keep happening but yeah i've been hit
plenty already and something happened on
sunday that caused his foot to be
injured to the point where he's getting
treatment on it see that's how a guy who
fully participates in practice ends up
on the injury report because he's in the
training room and there's a record of
him getting treatment they have to
disclose it at that point if you don't
that's when you get busted by the league
so there's something up at the foot we
don't know which one didn't say left or
right but he's got a foot injury chris
and i think he'll keep playing yeah but
you have to you have to watch and wonder
yeah you know as he takes more contact
will he get to a point where he has to
miss him you're right well and we know
he's he's had some lower leg injuries
you know in his college career so that's
where you're a little just you know
cautious he's got injury history we know
that
he has taken a few hits here and there
you know and and you know i know he
laughed at all that and then you know i
hope he continues to take it serious
it's just a different world in the nfl i
don't know how to explain it when you
run the ball in college you feel like oh
whoa i'm tucking the ball away i might
be able to do something here even a big
lumbering you know stiff like myself
used to take off in college every now
and then and go whoa i'm going to get 10
12 yards here look at this in the nfl
the second you cross the line of
scrimmage you're like whoa they're
coming at me from everywhere and they're
mad as hell and they want to kill me and
it's just it's a different league and
you got to be careful and he's not going
to get away with some of the stuff he
got away with in the sec and we know he
didn't even get away with it there so
that's he's been pretty good so far i've
not taken those big hits and i just
would say that to him because i'm
rooting for the kid i like the kid a lot
get down get out of the way throw the
ball no one's gonna call you a chicken
if you slide or do anything like that
it's best for you to be out there for
your team healthy and going
i watched the movie invincible recently
for the first time in a long time and
one thing that that movie does very well
is convey yeah the chaos of football
that sense of it does oh god life comes
at you fast yeah on an nfl football
field it does it you know they do a good
job of kind of putting you in the helmet
and giving you a little bit of a little
bit of a feel
because that's what it is i mean you got
a helmet on and it's running and people
are yelling and you know it's shaken and
you know that that's the way it is
especially for the new guys now you know
patrick mahomes and aaron rodgers
they're probably seeing symphony and
everybody's going in slow motion because
they're so awesome that's what the good
players have but at first it is pure
chaos
well that's one thing to told me on
sunday as well it's already starting to
slow down for him which is good because
he does need to find a way
to be that
conductor
amid the chaos that does become a
symphony eventually otherwise you do get
hit you do get hurt and it does derail
your career
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports